- So basically you have
very low standards for me.
(laughs)
(jazzy music)
- Today my mom is gonna
make me a Tinder profile.
- I expect that my mom won't see
anybody that she likes on Tinder.
- Did you expect that I pick
out people that you don't like.
- I don't think my mom's
gonna agree with my taste.
She hasn't in the past.
- Well if I say no,
you're gonna get angry.
- I think I know what Katelyn's taste is.
- We'll see if my mom thinks she knows
what type of guys I like.
- Do you think I have a lot
of personality to offer?
- So you need to choose like six photos
that you think represents me well.
- Not that one, 'cause that's
actually my ex-girlfriend.
- It's an old photo.
- I like this one the best,
that's the cutest one.
- It looks like I'm a high schooler
so these guys are gonna be
swiping right on a high schooler.
- So now you're gonna set up
my description, like who I am.
- Sarcastic feminist with
a cutting sense of humor
who loves to eat and travel,
looking for someone to feed me.
- That sounds like I can't pay for myself.
- Brian is real sweet, has a
good heart, cool personality,
and a human.
- Minimum age is 18 and then
it goes up to like 55 plus.
- Yeah, I don't think so.
- 22 to 28.
- You don't see me as someone
who prefers older women?
- What can I say?
- I feel like he looks
like your little brother.
He can go left.
- She's too much.
- What's too much?
- Too much here, I think this is fake.
- I smoke a lot of marijuana,
no I don't think so,
and he didn't even spell marijuana right.
- If a girl too pretty, not easy.
- You're saying the more prettier,
the less likely they wanna be with me.
- You're better with somebody
a little bit more conservative.
- Okay, so what do you
do now when it's a match?
- So you can send them
a message right there.
- Oh hi, this is Brian's mom.
- Don't say this is your mom.
- Oh okay, pretend I'm Brian.
- I'm gonna lose her right away.
- I asked him how long he's
been living here and he says,
"A few months," and he
goes, "How do you like it?"
I like it.
- You look sweet, you're real pretty,
what do you think about me?
- This guy's actually replying to her.
Maybe he's a good match with my mom.
- My mom's already
creeping things out for me.
- Overall, just confirms my
thoughts about how my mom
has high standards, that's what it is.
I wouldn't expect her to
swipe right on many people.
- Would I let her do this again?
No way.
Just even the first try was a disaster.
- Those girls, they don't have good taste
'cause they don't reply
to you, 'cause you're.
- So then maybe it's me.
- No, it's them.
(precocious music)